daniel darc est ce que vous allez
régulièrement à l'église
je suis au temple ouais ouais 18 rue du
faubourg du temps 3 mars
est ce que vous faites des
accompagnements de gens malades
j'ai fait pendant pendant presque deux
ans aurait gelé personnes en fin de vie
est-ce qu'ils étaient inscrits sur les
listes électorales
je devrais dire oui non parce que vous
reboucher les tubes de dentifrice j'ai
toujours fait ça quand j'étais un gamin
la pire zhang tao reboucher les mêmes
sur le jeu perso je crois way for their
dos ne serait pas d'une petite crise
risque de vous regarder le journal de 20
heures sur tf1
non la première partie est ce que
marilyn manson vous fait peur non j'ai
peur pour lui je pense qu'il est en
train sincèrement
ce qu'ils se trompent complètement et
qui joue avec des choses qui contrôlent
pas il se rend pas compte de ce qui fait
lors il est sympa non ouais elle n'est
pas méchante 1 1
sympa julien lepers souci c'est sympa
allez pas méchante si ce n'est pas
méchant non plus il est très bien
finalement les radars ça peut économiser
des villes dans ce coma ouais c'est très
bien pour la lessive tu sais pas le
blanc est la couleur je mélange un peu
tout ça mais je suis pas beaucoup de
blancs remplis donc un mec bien
maintenant mais c'est quoi un mec bien
j'essaie je te dis j'essaye de cesser de
ne pas faire de mal voilà est-ce que
c'est ça être un mec bien j'essaie de
pas faire de mal